[Music]
what's shake and reject nation it's your
boy humble Stiltskin coming at you on a
hub day afternoon it's not been a
terrific day so far you know you ever
have one of those mornings where you
wake up and just enough time to discover
that you've failed at something basic
yeah so my day is not off to a terrific
start but if there's one thing that
never fails to make me feel better that
would be music and it just so happens
that one of my favorite current bands
released a new music video just recently
and I thought it would be nice to check
that out today it's also very sweet song
and Valentine's Days here so you
probably know a wall nation from their
hit songs and other songs too like kill
your hero is not your fault
I am Halloween bad wolf passion passion
and this is their newest single handyman
off their newest album which just came
out called here come the runts I'm
really enjoying that album so far a one
nation to me is an interesting band
I feel like Aaron Bruno has a very
authentic and a very natural voice and a
knack for songwriting I can't think of
an AWOL nation song that I dislike and
especially in the modern pop landscape I
just feel like he's a unique voice and
coming off of the first two albums that
are a lot more electronically influenced
and a lot more broad in terms of the
instrumentation and stuff I thought it
was cool that he decided to bring this
album back to a more rootsy feel to
bring forward the guitars and the bass
and the drums again because what I find
kind of fascinating about alienation is
that sale it's kind of a bigger moment
than I think people realize that song
got huge obviously but what it brought
with it to me anyway is a certain you
know sound that was on the rise but I
feel like that song really blew it up
and you can see so many people from the
contemporary pop and rock scene
borrowing some of those dark synth tones
and for a band that arguably helped kind
of foster the future of pop and rock
music and in ways the sounds that we're
hearing now I thought it was cool of
them to break away from those sounds on
this album go back to something a bit
more organic and with that comes this
music video and it's a very sweet song
I've heard the album through a couple
times already and this song every time
grabs me by the heartstrings so I'm
really excited to see this
so without further ado let's get into
this
[Music]
[Music]
my son
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
it's a fixed
[Music]
Oh Oh that was really sweet
I got to imagine that this is perhaps
maybe dedicated to his wife or something
like that because uh I know he did just
get married and that brought a big smile
to my face you know I I gotta say I do
appreciate especially nowadays that the
music industry has changed and the
nature of music videos has changed you
see a bit more of things that aren't so
high concept things that are more
performance-based things that are more
quietly conceptual and I thought this
video matched its song really really
well I mean it's such a sweet song and
and things that are dear always touched
me a lot and I feel like there's a dear
element to this just that conceit of him
looking back as an older man on his life
on his loves on his passions and whatnot
I thought this is a really beautifully
orchestrated music video in a very
subtle simple way and I appreciate
something like that like it's not the
flashiest imagery it's the highest
concept but I think it marries to the
song really well and it creates
something that's kind of heartfelt in
Universal in the process very
contemplative and I really appreciate it
for that fact this stuff like that
always touches me because I don't hear
it much especially in the popular
landscape I know for sure that he's a
student of the Everly Brothers among
other things that I got kind of a vibe
of that in this song but just as a music
video I thought this was really
beautiful in a subtle way because it's
just about him looking back on his life
and I feel like that ties into the vocal
theme really well that you know if only
yesterday took place tomorrow I'd pray
for sleep you know cuz because you want
to go back to the glory days and stuff
and relive all the wonderful memories
and even down to the way that they shot
it you know you see Aaron himself always
through a window with reflections and
stuff it's always a little fuzzy and you
have ostensibly the older version of him
you know later on in life looking back
retracing his steps revisiting all these
places that he went with such passion as
a young person and it's
cool in terms of just this song in this
album this is a big moment for them for
Aaron Bruno he's been in a number of
bands before AWOLNATION and Abel nation
is the one that really picked up and he
always strikes me as a very thoughtful
guy and this is a very thoughtful music
video too I think the all the parts are
really sweet the acoustic versus the
electric are balanced really well and it
gets pretty heavy in some of those
choruses but it never loses that feeling
at the center of it that little spark
that sweet feeling I think it's really
heartfelt I think the video is really
heartfelt and it's kind of beautiful to
see the projection of them growing old
together you know living their lives
doing what they love and I think just
the handyman motif is a really sweet one
as well and again it's exemplified in
just the little flourishes of this music
video both is a literal idea of a
handyman but also just that sweet idea
of like I'll be here to pick you up and
sort of help you repair the little
things the daily things the life things
it's really heartfelt in a way that is
simple and close to the ground but it
also has a lot of efficacy I just think
it's really nice metaphor the vibe
they're talking about with this out in
that coastal mountain vibe is very much
alive in the video and in the song and
again I I can very much hear that spirit
in the album and it's exemplified really
nicely here I think all the videos
they've done so far I've done a great
job of encompassing the themes of the
album passion with OGG D'Souza the
Brazilian skateboarder and then seven
six dynamite was filmed at there sort of
watering holes so I like that they're
tying in elements of the making of this
album into the videos and stuff and the
themes and all that and I think the song
does a nice job in general with its
sounds you know you have these really
sweet acoustic guitars that lead off the
track and then those electric guitars
kick in on the chorus and I and I
suppose that could have gone wrong but
here I feel like it again works really
nice I feel like the lower-end guitars
add a certain crunch and a certain
warmness to everything and then you have
these lead melodies that just grab you
by the heart you know and they kind of
take you off to some place it feels very
much like the passage of time and like
looking back and I don't know it just
kind of evokes that that feeling that
wanting to be there for somebody I feel
like just this whole song this whole
video everything comes together and
coalesce is in a really beautiful way
and it kind of looks around and it
counts for everything you know you could
read this as some kind of love song but
it also just seems like a reaction
to the world around through music you
know there are a lot of little touches
especially in the verses of this and I
think are really nice and that fit
together in really neat ways it has sort
of an every mannish sort of runt like
quality there's just a wave of heart and
authenticity that comes out of this for
me in a really wonderful kind of
beautiful way and you know it's
Valentine's Day I thought this might be
appropriate for Valentine's Day just
because it is such a sweet song and and
you could you know kind of put it on a
loving playlist for somebody but yeah
just just in terms of a simple well
executed well shot well thought-out
music video I thought this really hit
the mark I love that we finally got to
see Erin in action surfing because if
you know a well nation at all you know
that the ocean and surfing is a big
inspiration for them I just really like
this band in and what they do I feel
like they've got a good creative group
around them I'm always happy when they
come around and I can never wait to hear
more you know so uh if y'all haven't
checked out this album yeah go give here
come the runs to listen it's a lot of
fun it's got some hopeful vibes it's got
some heavy vibes there's a little
something for everybody I think
especially if you're in the guitar music
this actually did make me feel better
and that's the power of music and that's
the power of a good music video too
because I'm talking about so many movies
clearly the combination of images and
sounds is a very powerful sensory
experience and when things come together
as harmoniously as they do here as
naturally as they do here it makes it
really compelling for me anyway so thank
you guys for joining me as usual you can
see the full version of this reaction
over on our patreon and if you got
yourself a Valentine or just a loved one
you'd like to appreciate to show your
love to today maybe just send them that
song or something I don't know anyway
thanks for joining me and I'll see on
the next one
chitta cheer
you